Here comes trouble.
The tape is on the backside here now.
Why, why, why is this happening?
There is too much tape on the role.
Yeah, it’s too much because when it’s
to rewind it’s so close…
the tape will get out.
It’s gone in on the backside there.
I don’t know how this could happen.
I think Friday is a bad day for me
because when we were in London, and I was
in this, it was also Friday.
I don’t understand.
It’s something with Fridays…
Because it could have happened earlier this
week instead of Friday.
The sound is from ’68.
1968?
And then this is the sound right now?
Yeah.
Just that, what you hear from that is acoustic
sound from the bubbles.
I can show you…
You have some speakers down there?
This is the sound on the tape.
[bubble recording sounds]
Yeah?
That is the tape.
And that tape sound goes through here and
activates the pool.
In the beginning when they were going to show
this at some performance or something they
tried to activate the pool with some different
sounds.
But Rauschenberg wasn’t so happy with that,
what they had coming over.
So at the end, just some days before the opening,
they just put in air in the bubbles, and they
recorded the bubble sound.
So on the tape now, it’s just the bubbles
sound that activates the bubbles again.
I can put in a CD player and play a CD if
you want to, your favorite music.
And you can see…
I think it would be nice to see how, if you
have a piece of classical music, with very
slow violins in the beginning and the crescendo
in the end…
and then at the crescendo, every bubbles are
coming up together and yeaaahhhh!
Okay, there it is…
One, two, three…
♫ “…to pay the bills I have to pay”
♫
♫ “Ain't it sad” ♫
♫ “And still there never seems to be a
single penny left for me” ♫
♫ “That's too bad” ♫
♫ “In my dreams I have a plan” ♫
♫ “If I got me a wealthy man” ♫
♫ “I wouldn't have to work at all, I'd
fool around and have a ball” ♫
♫ “Money, money, money” ♫
♫ “Must be funny” ♫
♫ “In the rich man's world” ♫
♫ “Money, money, money” ♫
♫ “Always sunny” ♫
♫ “In the rich man's world” ♫
♫ “Aha aha” ♫
♫ “All the things I could do” ♫
♫ “It's a rich man's world!” ♫
[cheers]
Yeah!
Thank you!
Gunnar!
Yeah!
That’s fantastic.
Yeah.
Great.
Okay, back to work!
Back to work!
[laughter]